est ce que c'est un jour hors wifi ou
swing on m'en fiche mois de la saint
valentin je trouve que ça savoir rien ah
j'aime pas la faute des hauts revenus
c'est juste une fête pour payer ça sert
à rien déjà la première partie du coeur
c'est la partie est de quelqu'un ainsi
quelqu'un cette personne et l'autre
c'est une personne que l'ufa beyou
foncia plaisir à être donné tu as des
gens qui rougissent cheap et guettent le
coeur qui bat plus vite la fête des
amoureux message lui ce qu'il faudrait
qu'ils ont mené au moins cinq dans
l'année tu sais ce que c'est la saint
valentin
oui c'est quoi c'est quelque chose on
fait des cadeaux à ses amoureux toujours
juste une fleur si tous vont aller
manger au restaurant ensemble ressent
quand même un sentiment
ouais j'sais pas je ressens bonheur un
battement de kara j'ai dit sentiment que
les gens que j'aime pas ça fait qu'on le
trouve beau et puis qu'on a envie de le
voir tous les jours
à quoi ça sert d'être amoureux bas
sardines et des égos et à trois ans et
demi comme moi et vous allez faire quoi
plus tard bah on va chars des bijoux à
j'ai dit qu'on est marié récup et ils
ont dit quoi papa et maman sont d'accord
ils ont dicté ce mois moore eux aussi
voilà